How Dreams Work.
Our dreams combine verbal, visual,...
...and emotional stimuli into a nonsensical but entertaining story line.
We can sometimes even solve problems in our sleep.
Many experts disagree on exactly what the purpose of our dreams might be.
Are they strictly random brain impulses,...
...or are our brains actually working through issues from our daily life while we sleep?
Should we even interrupt our dreams?
Do you guarantee that dreams are worth thinking about?
Many say, "Are you serious? Of course!"...
...and add that we have a great deal to learn from our dreams.
For example,...
...Sigmund Freud said that our dreams represent the desires that we are unable to express in a social setting.
Dreams ensure that the unconscious mind...
...acts out those unacceptable thoughts and desires.
More recently, around 1973,...
...a researcher named Allan Hobson said...
...that dreams were simply the result of random electrical brain impulses that pulled...
...imagery from traces of experience stored in the memory.